Now, before we actually do step two, let's have a brief review of what step two actually means.
So, to show that shortest tour is NP-hard, which would then make it NP-complete,
because we've already shown that it is in NP,
what do we need to show?
Do we need to show that the input for some NP-complete problem
can be transformed into an input for shortest tour.
And, of course, if this input here is a yes for this NP-complete problem,
then it has to be yes for shortest tour here as well.
If it's the no it's has to be a no.
Or do we need to show that the input for shortest tour can be transformed
into an input for some other NP-complete problem?
Basically, I would like you to review here which direction these transformations work.
Of course, we'll always make the assumption that the transformation is in polynomial time.